kubernetes is an open source container
orchestration tool which has gained
immense popularity over the last several
years
as more companies began to adopt
kubernetes there came to be a demand for
kubernetes to be provided as a managed
service
that's where google kubernetes engine
comes in i'm caslin fields and i'm a
developer advocate here at google cloud
where i focus on google kubernetes
engine or gke as well as open source
kubernetes and today we're going to take
a look at some gke essentials around the
different types of cluster modes
available through gke
[Music]
kubernetes is a platform for running
applications by using the kubernetes
software to create a cluster of machines
allowing you to run your applications
while abstracting the hardware that the
applications are running on
when running open source kubernetes
clusters from scratch there are a number
of components of the cluster itself
which you will need to understand
these include the control plane which
itself is made up of several components
as well as provisioning and management
of the underlying compute nodes
security and networking configuration of
the nodes as well as the cluster as a
whole
patching and upgrades of both the
cluster software and the compute nodes
that make up the cluster
monitoring or observability components
as well as management tools such as
policy configuration capabilities
scaling tools such as pod level and
cluster or node level auto scalers
and availability and reliability
capabilities and tools
some of these components are built into
kubernetes itself and some are essential
capabilities which may require
additional tooling
when running kubernetes from scratch you
will need to develop a level of
proficiency across all of these
categories and be prepared for the
maintenance configuration and
exploration running a do-it-yourself
cluster will require
google kubernetes engine or gke is a
managed kubernetes service from google
cloud it allows you to spin up a
kubernetes cluster quickly with many of
the more complex components of the
system being deployed and managed by
google
this way you can focus more on running
the applications that matter to you on
kubernetes rather than spending as much
time understanding kubernetes itself
there are two modes of operation in gke
each is designed to allow users
different levels of involvement with
kubernetes itself
both autopilot mode and standard mode
gke clusters take some of the management
overhead of kubernetes clusters off your
hands
standard mode offers a higher degree of
control
the kubernetes control plane and some
other considerations are handled behind
the scenes by google but you will still
need to manage the nodes of the
kubernetes cluster gke autopilot mode
provides an even more hands-off
experience with smart defaults and even
less management overhead gke autopilot
lets you have more time and resources to
spend on your own applications if you
want minimal cluster management overhead
in order to focus more of your time and
resources on the applications you need
to run you may prefer gke autopilot mode
autopilot mode gke clusters provision
infrastructure resources as needed for
kubernetes workloads this means that you
pay per pod or per workload rather than
per node
the nodes of the kubernetes cluster are
automatically provisioned and managed
which means that there should be no need
to dedicate time and resources to node
management and upgrades any
infrastructure auto scaling will be
handled automatically by the autopilot
mode cluster however you'll need to
configure any desired auto scaling at
the workload or pod level
if you've been using kubernetes for some
time and have developed skills and
processes that require greater control
and insight into the cluster you may
prefer standard mode
standard mode the control plane and some
aspects of monitoring and management are
handled for you
but the user still must manage the nodes
of the kubernetes cluster themselves
this means that in standard mode you'll
pay per node for the instance types that
you select
standard mode clusters will require you
to dedicate some time and resources to
node management and upgrades
for securing and maintaining your gke
standard mode clusters worker nodes be
sure to familiarize yourself with the
gke hardening guide which is available
in the google cloud documentation all
four dimensions of auto scaling are
available to standard mode clusters
but you'll have to manually configure
any desired auto scalers at both the
workload and infrastructure levels for
each cluster
as a managed kubernetes service google
kubernetes engine provides users with an
easier path to getting started running
their applications with kubernetes
between standard mode and autopilot mode
gke provides different levels of control
and flexibility depending on how
hands-on teams want to be with managing
their kubernetes clusters
with the concepts discussed in this
video we're confident you'll be on your
way to building a gke cluster that suits
your needs you can get started with gke
by visiting google cloud console and
checking out the links below and stay
tuned for our next videos where we dive
deeper into gke topics
[Music]
you